I don't want to live my life on social I
think it's doing a real number on
people's mental state I think it's
horrible for kids and families and
marriages I just do but that's why I
tell you I'm not on it I don't live on
social and I don't think you should
either I think you should Outsource it
to people that want to do it and I think
we really need to stop being so caught
up in numbers and vanity metrics and
trying to be known like do you really
care about being known or do you just
want to pay the bills and then some I
don't know that's no judgment but I
don't need to be known I like making
money though but you know that's the
truth because I don't want to work that
hard I want to enjoy my life I want to
live life I want to do things I don't
want to be stuck editing a video I don't
want to be stuck feeling like oh I
have to post right now oh my God I have
to post I have to post that person has
more followers than me I don't care I
Outsource that and then I Mastermind the
marketing piece of it and think about
how can we serve our customers what do
they need what can we create for our
customers what can I develop for them so
that we're building our email list so
we're building those relationships